when a screenwriter is just starting out
do you advise that they write a
protagonist in their own gender or do
you think it's okay to switch genders I
think we should be able to imagine
anything any century any gender any
situation the desperate were for and to
try and confine ourselves to one thing
to being only ourselves is a sort of
failure of imagination when you sit down
to write something do you imagine the
implication of the greater whole of what
or how it may affect people or is it
just simply a story you want to tell
that you have to get out of your own
being or do you imagine who might that
audience be once it's finally finished
you work very tentatively you work
sentence by sentence so if you start
thinking about large questions like what
is the audience for this going to be or
what are the implications of this then
you're not thinking about what you
should be thinking about which is an
extent ins which is the next paragraph
which it should there be full stop here
or a semicolon which is how am I going
to put this planet dialogue in so that
you work tentatively and gradually
afterwards you're gonna big thoughts
when you're working you must have small
thoughts and lastly how do you rest your
writing mind I watched the documentary
Joni Mitchell she's talked about how she
rests her singing do you think it by
painting do you do anything that's a
different medium that's still creative
but you feel you can recharge by going
away from writing play tennis
how does that how does that help it it
helps enormously because that whole idea
of how much you think and deliberate in
a game of tennis and a much as pure
instinct so you often play your best
game when you merge strategy with
instinct and it's the same with writing
thank you